الكتب اللي بيكفروه عليها دي هي اللي اخذ
بيها الدكتوراه في الجامعه وهي اللي اخذ
بيها الجوايز والاخذ بها ثم فجاه تصبح هي
اداه تكفيره
الاعتقاد مصر ابو زيد في مجازيه بعض
التعبيرات القرانيه وتاريخيه بعض الاحكام
المستمده من القران
المجاز
مصر اراد ان يستدعي هذا وانما تحدث عن
وجود المجاز ووجود الرمل داخل القران
الكريم قال ان هذا له تاسيس اينما تحدث
عما يعرف بالتاريخيه تم تحريف هذا المستوى
عندما نتحدث الان بمنتهى القبول وبلا
اختلاف بين جميع المسلمين على ان حتى
يعطوا الجزيه على ان هذا سياق تاريخي
مونتاج هل احد يقول اننا نعطي الفيزياء
الان او ان غير المسلمه يتحدث عن ان هذا
سياق تاريخي ممتاز عندما نتحدث عن ايات
الايمان والعبيد داخل القران الكريم هل
نحن نتحدث عنها الان على انها سياق
اجتماعي اذا عدنا الى 200 سنه قبل ذلك لا
يجر احد ان يقول هذا لان هذا القران
ويقولون كيف لا يقولون كيف لا يكون هناك
ايمان وهذا كان يحدث فعلا وكان صارمون
بهدف بحق شرعي الذي فعله نص انه كان سابق
للزمالك